a lot of people are calling Sweden right
now
hello hey how's it going good
who am I talking to Peter I pizza my
name is Felix how can I help you well I
wanted to know do you watch YouTube he
just hung up
hey I was going bros my name is P so
today I'm gonna call a Swede Sweden just
implemented this feature so you call a
number and you get connected to a random
Swedish person let's check it out hey
how's it going
no thank you
I wanted to ask you are you familiar
with Judy pie what what PewDiePie
PewDiePie yes what I'm not making you
mean pie you're not baking no that's
cool yeah you know my first caller yeah
it's really funny I found out today so
so really I was like you want to change
funny cat videos is that correct
yes yes number one anomaly or number two
yeah okay I wanted to ask you are you
for do you watch any YouTube yeah I do
yeah are you familiar with PewDiePie
yeah do you watch P deep I know hey
how's it going hello this is PewDiePie
alright
this is PewDiePie
cutie pie what would make you watch
YouTube hey let's shouting I think I
knew it I'm the guy that plays video
games let you heard me shout from you
why is it so awkward
am i that awkward tears just be talking
to you like the parents of all my fans
hello hello dad yes what the [ __ ] this
is PewDiePie calling are you familiar
hey Peter PewDiePie
you don't think it's me what yeah you
spell it like mark-5 what if I do a
really good pity pie impression I don't
think I don't miss me have you heard PD
pie yeah that's cool is he your favorite
youtuber not really damn it they hung up
against
I'm conducting a search for if people
know about the Lord and Savior PewDiePie
wrong number well I am calling to tell
people about our Lord and Savior Edgar
they Augen savin yes I will find you my
I will look for you and I will vist you
brofist you are you crazy
no I'm Peter pie mom hello
sash song you sing along yes yeah happy
to meet you pewdiepie can I tell you a
joke
yeah what our beautiful women in Sweden
calm
what tourists oh alright press that was
a lot of fun I it was painful for me
just just so you know let me know if you
enjoyed leave a like if you're dead
and as always blew their fist
come please